los números de muertos y de
desaparecidos continúan aumentando en
esta crisis que afecta particularmente a
alemania en el occidente del país pero
que también se evidencia ya en otros
países europeos como bélgica y los
países bajos aquí en alemania los
esfuerzos están centrados en lo más
urgente en esas labores de rescate en
las zonas más afectadas pero también ya
se está empezando a discutir en los
efectos a mediano y a largo plazo en
particular en las labores de
reconstrucción y de ahí que la
cancillera alemana angela merkel esté en
contacto con los ministros de finanzas y
del interior para determinar exactamente
cómo será esa ayuda una vez terminen las
labores inmediatas de rescate y también
se está empezando ya a discutir las
causas el impacto del cambio climático
un tema que está otra vez en el centro
del debate político aquí en alemania
cuando faltan pocos meses para las
elecciones federales que marcarán el
comienzo de una nueva era política aquí
en alemania